[Musique]
faire de la sécurité routière une action
forte de leur mandature c'est
l'engagement pris par ces collégiens
membre du conseil départemental des
jeunes au sein de l'hémicycle pendant
une matinée ils vont débattre avec les
acteurs de la prévention sur les dangers
de la vitesse de l'alcool et des
stupéfiants est vrai que ces jeunes
conseillers départementaux aujourd'hui
on lâche en ce2 de comment de pouvoir
travailler en direct avec les forces de
l'ordre avec les intervenants du
rectorat avec les associations parce
qu'ils sont représentant des jeunes
d'eau de part leur leur leur
participation aujourd'hui on va la
demande est bien évidemment de réveiller
le tout dans l'eure dans leur propre
établissement
130 jeunes issus des 80 collèges de
l'île participent à cette journée
d'action sur la sécurité routière
tout l'après midi des ateliers pratiques
sensibilise ses jeunes à la prévention
comme ici la formation aux gestes de
premiers secours
animé par la protection civile j'arrive
face à un danger qui peut être contrôlé
je le supprime j'arrive face à un danger
qui ne peut pas être contrôlé donc je ne
pourrais pas parler la victime sur place
je vais soustraire victime la zone de
danger après quand je vais t'en sécurité
ce qui se passe un peu plus loin c'est
la police nationale qui prend le relais
et aborde les dangers de la conduite
pour les cyclomotoristes à l'aide d'un
tueur vous m les policiers contrôlent la
vitesse des véhicules et sensibilise
ces jeunes aux risques qu'ils peuvent
encourir 10 % quasiment des tués sur
l'île de la réunion entre 15 et 17 ans
donc ces trois années charnières
c'est l'année où peut-être on va être en
conduite accompagnée selanne est aussi
ce sont les années où on a le scooter
on va commencer à les sortir hors de
l'agglomération on va sortir avec des
plus âgés on va être passée j'ai
peut-être d'un véhicule pour aller dans
un établissement nuit qui va peut-être
être conduit par quelqu'un qui aura vu
donc effectivement il faut que déjà pour
eux et puis pour passer un message
qu'ils le soient bien au courant de tout
ce que puisse encourir en termes de
législation certes mais finalement en
termes de sécurité de leur intégrité
physique surtout c'est quelque chose
d'acquis c'est un beau coup à coeur
parce que c'est pas des choses que les
jeunes ont l'habitude de voir tous les
jours c'est pas des choses qui se font
naturellement dans les collèges il faut
tout le temps demandé du coup on va
mettre dans les semaines à venir le
bureau du conseil départemental des
jeunes continuera cette action de
sécurité routière en se rendant dans un
centre de rééducation pour les
accidentés de la route
donc en fait c'est une politique globale
de prévention prévention contre les
accidents de la circulation
prévention contre les addictions et nous
voulons c'est diane collégiens parce que
voyez c'est durant cette phase d'âge que
beaucoup de choses se passent
et bien nos collégiens ce sont les
citoyens de demain nous devons leur
donner tous les moyens pour réussir leur
scolarité mais aussi réussi à la
citoyenneté
[Musique]